originally I applied for a surf grant
for a project that was entitled
photography botany and women I knew I
wanted to incorporate women and plants
and flowers into a photograph I wasn't
sure exactly how yet but I went to the
hunt Institute in the beginning of the
summer to do some research there
happened to be a huge exhibit called
floors lexicon which was on the language
of flowers and I got really inspired by
it and I decided that I want to
concentrate on a project that focused on
Victorian culture I decided that I was
going to create dresses out of various
flowers to create a modern language of
flowers book I realized that biological
photography was something I was really
interested in as well so I decided that
I wanted to find a way with my surf
grant to connect portraits of women
portraiture with biology and more
scientific ways of image making I think
that getting to spend an entire summer
developing this original idea and I even
tried to develop an original process it
really inspired me for the future and
helped me understand the importance of
making making contributions to my fields
my advisor this summer's Patricia Murray
it is who is a faculty member in the
school of art and which should
definitely help me this summer by
pushing me to do things that I wouldn't
ordinarily do or I didn't want to do it
definitely taught me that research is a
process and it's not something that can
be done in a week but it's something
that can be done over an expansion
period of time and it's definitely
taught me personally more about not only
biology but also who I am as an artist
when I present a meeting of the minds
I'm hoping just to show that art
research is possible and that
photography and art are things that you
can research
so over the past year I've been doing a
lot of work on the layout of my
presentation in book form I've been
working a lot on perfecting the images
that I created over the summer as well
as working on layout and creating some
new images as well as I continued
through the project I'd walk away from
pieces and then come back and realize
that need to be changed or go to
something small that didn't bother me
before but now it started to bother me
so I think my project really needed a
year of completion for completion next
week at meeting the mines they'll have
about 10 printed pieces and then I'll
have my book on display for people to
read I'm excited to to be able to
present my project talk with people why
project and also for people to see it in
book form to be able to turn pages and
read a little bit about what I learned
there's a lot of people that have been
stopping by and asking me about the
project it's really nice to have like
visual components from the book and then
the actual book as well because people
are able to see it larger and then they
can actually feel the pages and turn
through and I'm having a lot of fun
explaining my project people seem to be
pretty interested in it and they really
liked hearing about the process which I
enjoy explaining to a lot of people have
been suggesting to me that I explore
contacting publishers and maybe trying
to see if i can get it beyond
self-publishing which I think might be a
good idea